man am i tense i mean i'm just
frazzled i'm worn down to the bone to
the nub
between february sweeps code orange i've
had it
i need to relax that's why i came here
to the bliss spawn 57th street
supposed to be the best spa in manhattan
look at that the letters wiggle it's a
pretty good spa
let's find out what's going on and see
if i can get some major help
your name is jordan jordan i need a lot
of help
i need an incredible amount of health
i've got a lot of pressure i'm feeling
rundown i feel lethargic uh
i have headaches frequent headaches my
eyes sometimes cross for no reason
my scalp is itchy and irritable
uh my bowels are irregular and
uh irresponsible my jaw
is uh is sore and swollen
um the back of my neck feels sort of
like the front of my neck
okay you know what i mean you know when
the back starts to feel like the front
what's my menu for you man spa menu did
you say for you ma'am
man i thought you said for you man
hey what is lymphatic drainage that
sounds like something actually
physically when they're going through
it's a very light touch massage where
almost like a feather points on the body
when you drain the lymphatic system what
are you draining it into is there a
bucket
next to the not exactly it causes
everything to go through the
normal drainage that routine much
quicker so
you're talking about urine something
like that yeah so basically you take a
massage and then you go and you urinate
you'd want to let go of any toxins that
may have been released during the
treatment
so are you urinating during the massage
or after the massage i
after the treatment does anyone urinate
during the massage not that i'm aware of
no
okay i heard that was i heard larry king
was into that
[Laughter]
do you think that was funny that's
amazing yeah be honest you liked it the
image of larry king
did you like that larry king urinating
well then everybody's happy okay let's
go let's do it let's go this way
look at that you do your hair and then
ah
doing my hair is too poofy
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you got to admit that i'm i probably
look i'm in the upper ten percent of how
guys look in a robe
okay um yeah
yeah what's let's say i just have a lot
of more musculature than the average
person
would that make it more difficult for
someone to massage me not a skilled
massage therapist no but what if i mean
like i'm talking about like muscles that
are like muscles on top of muscles that
then have their own muscles
do you feel that yeah what is that this
feels like like that feels like muscles
on top of muscles
that then have their own muscles yeah
that's called tri-musculature
[Music]
i'll be doing your facial and marie will
be doing your body treatment and massage
so here we go
[Music]
so i'm going to be cryogenically
preserved for a thousand years is that
the idea
that's part of the service it's a
massage a facial
and you wake up in the year 2225
where robots are our masters
and the world is ruled by a council of
nine
led by overlord quang
all hail quang
wouldn't i get the same effect if i
stuck my head out a cab window
that's nice right there that's a lot of
tension in the arms isn't there
no but i use my hands a lot when i do
the talk show you know what i mean
this is the part of my body that i use
the most the face
and the arms like look at this check
this out
our next guest is someone i think you're
going to really enjoy
please put your hands together for
emmanuel lewis
[Music]
[Laughter]
no
you know it's what's weird if i were to
flex right now the two of you would go
flying out of the room
[Music]
[Applause]
so just to give you a demonstration
these are very funny looking i could do
a very funny physical bit with this
yes but i won't because i'm too classy
more treatments this week what's
happening when you describe what's
happening okay right now i'm just
mixing up the carrot with the essential
oils it's a little warm
i should probably mention that i'm
violently allergic to carrots
is that a problem you look like a sexy
tugboat captain right now
yeah weird
you don't hear that a lot sexy tugboat
captain do that
okay i think the carrot stuff is making
me a little high
well congratulations you've made my body
more orange than it already was
terrific you know what this is like this
is like an autopsy for a guy that was
killed by a flying pumpkin
that's what this is
i'm feeling a lot better all that stress
is gone thanks to bliss
now all i have to do is get dressed
[Music]
[Applause]
you